je venais là et a fait les études de
droit je crois donc il devrait se
référer à ses études
mais on met derrière derrière la
provocation manifeste
il ya une forme de perte le sang froid
madame jourdain viens de le dire à juste
titre une continuons notre travail dans
la sérénité avec l'objectif de faire
émerger les éléments de la vérité pour
informer le peuple français puisque nous
sommes ses représentants du bon
fonctionnement ou du mauvais
fonctionnement de l'elysée autour de la
question de la sécurité du président de
la république monsieur benalla
manifestement occupé une place
particulière ce que nous voulons
simplement c'est comprendre comprendre
pour ensuite faire des préconisations
c'est aussi notre travail